MAGNUS HYTTSEN: Do you
want to build better apps?
In that case, you've
come to the right place,
because we're now proud to
release Google Play Services
7.0.
And that's exactly what
Google Play Services
is all about-- enabling
you to build better apps.
In this release, we've packed
a number of new features,
and we also have
a brand new API.
So join us, and
let's check it out.
Let's start with location,
location, and location.
I mean, what can be
more basic than location
in a mobile environment?
GOOGLE NOW VOICE:
Connectivity, perhaps.
MAGNUS HYTTSEN: All right,
but you get the point.
Location is always important.
You want to know where
your friends are,
what interesting
stuff there is nearby,
or just to keep track
of where you are.
That's where Fused Location
Provider comes into play.
The Fused Location Provider
can identify location,
combining information from a
number of different sources,
such as the GPS, Wi-Fi network
information, or the cell
network that you're
connected to.
But how can your app
detect and ensure
that location settings
are enabled on the device,
and have them turned
on if they're not?
Well up to now, this has
not been straightforward.
But with this
release it will be,
since you can now check
if the necessary location
settings are enabled for a given
location request to succeed.
And if there are
possible improvements,
you can display a
one touch control--
like the one you see
here-- for the user
to change their settings
without leaving your app.
So this is great news for your
app, as well as your users.
For example, when Google
Maps integrated the location
settings dialog, there
was a dramatic increase
in the number of users who
were in a good location state.
So this is important stuff.
And that brings us over
to-- yeah, that's right,
we've got a new API.
Let's welcome the Places API
with a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
The Places API uses
Google databases
of places and business to
identify the things that
exists at a location.
So for example, if this is
my current longitude latitude
location, then the
Places API could
identify that I am actually
in Building 48 at Googleplex
where I am recording this video.
So how do you add
this to your app?
Well, first of all, there
is a built-in picker.
The user picks
their current place,
and your app can get all
the relevant information
about the place-- such as name,
address, phone number, website,
and even more.
But that's not all.
You can also
programmatically ask
the API for the
user's current place
through the getCurrent
Place method.
And it's also possible to
report that the user is
at a particular place
using the addPlace method.
So Places-- a great
new API to use,
turning the world into
real life objects.
And we've got a
separate DevByte going
into more detail
on this API, so be
sure to check the references
at the end of this video.
Now turning to Google Fit.
In this release, we split the
single fitness API constant
into six different
API constants.
Why?
Because this significantly
reduces the memory footprint
for Google Fit apps,
in particular for apps
that are running
in the background.
And there's just no limit
to the types of fitness data
that you want to
measure and record.
So therefore, we've added two
more data types, namely-- body
fat and sleep.
What the heck?
Hey, no pranks!
New slide, new slide!
Whew.
[GROWL]
Those are the Google Fit
enhancements in this release.
So go out there and
create great fitness apps.
And wrapping it
up with Play Game
Services, where we've added
the Nearby Connections API.
If your app implements this,
it allows Android devices
to connect to an Android TV and
be used as a remote controller,
for example, when playing games.
And that's it for Release
7.0 of Google Play services.
And remember, when you
use Google Play Services,
you build better apps.
And now it's your turn to
go out there and create
those great apps!
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.